all right about that anonymous op-ed by
a so called senior official in the New
York Times trashing the president for
his style and coarseness yep they went
after Trump for being Trump I know
shocking The Times says this story was
published at the request of the author
which is the way The Times used to sell
classified ads next time I want to do
1,200 words on the destructiveness of
the mainstream media I'll just call
ahead and make a reservation I joke that
only works if you're in the resistance
where you can claim it's about restoring
civility but it's really about unseating
Trump but within all this faux ninis
only one sentence really mattered when
Captain anonymous said the country is
already safer and more prosperous wait a
minute so the country is safer and more
prosperous under Trump but not nicer to
dolphins or more likely to recycle let's
impeach this guy yep just too silly
variables Security and Prosperity which
happened to be the best variables ever
seriously then what's left to critique
his style Trump's a big meanie
he's worse than Darth pls tell it to HR
I'll take the deeds you cry about the
words because we already get it Trump's
an intense boss who asks tons of
questions and makes you feel bad because
he's not like your old boss the one that
almost sank the company also Trump never
buys doughnuts and leaves his dirty
coffee mug in the sink so if you believe
that this Times piece hurts Trump you
might be dumb enough to read The Times
it doesn't hurt him a bit the scoop
Trump's not nice that's not journalism
that's clickbait so well done New York
Times you may be the paper of record but
it's a broken one you forgot that he
microwaves cauliflower yes
[Music]
yes yes it eats fish in the green room
absolutely disgusting I have to go to
dr. sapphire first because you sound
like a character from a Marvel comic I
am dr. sapphire doesn't this OP head
validate what people believe the deep
state is and that Trump is actually it
will appear to be the victim
to many of his supporters but I'll be
honest I can't put much merit in a self
congratulatory letter that it's you know
behind a cloak of anonymity because you
can say anything you want if you're not
putting your name behind it and a part
of this inside the letter they were
essentially saying you know don't worry
America adults are in the white house
but you know what they're doing they're
causing more mass hysteria what they
could have done if they're really
wanting to make people feel better about
what's going on is to actually discuss
the accomplishments that the
administration has achieved in the last
couple of years that would let America
feel a little bit better about these
adults being in said white house this is
just another provocative thing and if
you aren't going to put your name on it
you can't refute it mm-hmm
it's I find it to be very pathetic Jesse
why is this why should this person
remain anonymous if he comes out he's
gonna be a mythical folk hero to like
half all the media and the Democrats
yeah he's gonna land a gig at MSNBC and
he might already have it or at CNN we
were joking in the green room you know
who do you think it is who do you think
it is I don't think it's that funny I
think this is very very serious and it's
probably the biggest scandal in my
opinion within the Trump administration
so far all of the other scandals have
been about personnel and and bickering
and something crazy Trump said
off-the-record this this is a
conspirator and he's got a cabal of
other conspirators inside the White
House getting paid by the taxpayer he's
not elected
he's got buddies and they're preventing
the president for executing his vision
for making America great again it's
incredibly dangerous there's no way this
guy's ever going to be identified
because I don't think sessions is
capable of smoking this person out we
know what his motivation is it's
self-centered we had a mole here at Fox
News and he was smoked out in about less
than 48 hours and his motivation was a
cry for help
and a cry for attention and this is
exactly what this is and it reminds me
of Peter struck remember Peter struck he
was an egomaniac who thought it was his
duty even though he wasn't elected to
protect the country from Donald Trump
and he took really bad actions to do
that behind the scenes this is the exact
same thing and I'm really worried about
it I really uh there's merit there's
truth to this do you think it's actually
occurring or they just stink saying this
is a fear factor my theory is it's it's
a class of management styles they're not
used to working for a boss they're used
to working for a politician that's my
theory
you know what cuz cuz businessmen when
businessmen do things they do it right
away and they do it now and it's very
impulsive and it's what the CEO wants it
appears politicians usually right but
Paulo do you think the markets move fast
you gotta you got to move quickly
politicians they consults with allies
with their advisors with everybody
around them and it takes forever to get
anything done and then Trump comes in
here says let's rip up the trade deal
with South Korea or ask a lot of
questions terrifies people because a lot
of these people are Wall Street guys and
they don't want to ruin the markets they
don't want to affect the markets and a
lot of things are done in order for Wall
Street not to take hits but I think look
at Wall Street right now is on a pretty
good run all right at speaking of a good
run one I feel like this is like a game
of Clue like who could this be
could it be miss Scarlett or mr. peacock
mrs. peacock
I've never played clue well I know that
Dana's my lodestar on this I think that
would indicate Mike Pence's the suspect
although he says he's not the guy I'd be
speechwriter could be I don't think so
no because I think the times understands
that once you say it's a senior
administration official given the
possibility this person is out it you
better have a senior administration
official and not somebody on the back
bench but I'm taken by your monologue
because to me again Kim you seem to want
to normalize minimalize never ever pay
attention to Trump and I must say true
here's a point here's a point of
agreement I have with you guys I think
whoever wrote it really needs to stand
up because to my mind what this is is
Republicans in the administration it's
kind of saying hey you know what we
understand this guy maybe is not fit to
be President and we're here we're
watching him we're cautious about
everything things are not going well by
the way despite what you hear from Greg
I mean the fact is greatest economy in
years oh let me just say militarily
unbelievable because a great country has
been
and keeps going despite his antics but I
must say his numbers according to the
American people the lowest for any
president ahead of them you don't have
to like somebody to admit that ok great
job I say but the said that the key
thing here to me is that you have other
publications Axios saying peoples have
this are saying the same things oh I
could have written that inside the White
House administration officials telling
Axios you have the book from Bob
Woodward you have the Michael Wolfe book
you have the OMA they're all the same
story right but this guy is not making
rational decisions and he's scaring the
people in the White House all right so
Dana to his point I would I would argue
and you can degree that ok none of these
complaints are new we know what Trump is
about he's mercurial he's brash he asks
a lot of questions and a lot of
questions are innocently naive because
he's not a politician and then I think
that this article is turning into
management he's being managed by a staff
as evidence that he's dangerous I don't
see that but I said yesterday I think
that this person should definitely
resign there's a lot of benefits that
you get from being a senior
administration official no matter I mean
but that could also include like the
deputy undersecretary of the
such-and-such division at the Department
of Transportation I mean that's right I
don't think that they they don't have a
cabinet member or something like that
saying this because that would be
ridiculous and I don't think that
anybody in this cabinet would be so
cowardly to do this and hunt hide behind
anonymity and I think also just be quiet
be impossible to keep it a secret
here's the thing though about this
person they think they're doing such a
good job of keeping the country safe
from him but what this really does it's
hugely it's very aggravating to a
president and what they're saying is
that they're responsible to keeping the
presidency from devolving into something
that none of us want right but the
President of the United States no matter
who he or she is has so much on their
plate so much responsibility the
number-one thing is to protect the
American people from all threats that's
that is the most important job
so if you are really actually worried
about his state of mind
why aggravate him further by issuing an
op-ed that does nothing but just provide
you with some sort of cover so that when
you go out to seek some sort of private
sector position you can say I was the
one behind I picked up on this and
respond to your dinner to my mind this
person says that Trump is detrimental to
the United and resign well that's right
but the other thing that they say that
caught my attention was what about the
25th
Liz Warren yes all right so this to
Juan's point she said if senior
administration officials think the
president the United States is not able
to do his job then they should invoke
the 25th amendment I think she is right
that's what I was about to say to Dana
that in fact if you want to say this guy
says or a woman said they should say
they don't want to spark a
constitutional crisis otherwise they
would invoke the 25th because what
they're saying is this guy is I don't
think they believe it they don't believe
it invoke that impeachment so if we
write but my point is that this person
in writing this is making the case this
person the president is a danger to us
all to a safer and prosperous one what
about the idea that he thinks huh so
what if Russia's interfering in our
elections not a big deal coordination we
just killed a bunch of Russians what
about the idea that oh I'm going to
attack all the law enforcement in our
country because they should be
protecting me not the American people
cops love all the cops we love him
oh please FBI CIA they don't love him
what about the corruption in this
administrative what about the racism in
this abiding as you see the race and
talk to you about danger because this is
not a dangerous situation Isis has been
destroyed
there's more Peace Prize facts and
stroyed there's ladies present
maybe not too hard around about nine
POTUS is back the stock market is doing
because of Trump's vision oh is it thank
you all Trump's vision Thank You jobs in
this country because of Trump not living
in dangerous times you're safe
we're all safe and a lot more safer than
under Barack Obama take off those
rose-colored glasses brother yeah put
some on